begin with some sad news a shooting
after a high school graduation ceremony
in Virginia this was in Richmond
yesterday during what should have been a
moment of celebration for families there
instead two people killed including an
18 year old who had graduated just
minutes earlier five people wounded
overall and a witness said that some of
these victims were still in their cap
and gowns Nicole Sanga is in Richmond
Forest covering this story Nicole that
there are no words but please give it a
shot good morning
Tony there are no words and police have
arrested a 19 year old suspect who they
say will be charged with two counts of
second-degree murder the shooting
happened as dozens filed out of a nearby
graduation ceremony at the Altria
theater behind me and into this park
where the shooter opened fire
several people shot a couple of Mayday
chaos erupted as shots were fired in
Monroe Park Tuesday afternoon we have
multiple reports of shootings in Monroe
Park the area was filled with families
celebrating Huguenot High School
graduates with all graduates of the
class of 2023 please stand together
who left from the Altria theater
directly across the street just moments
earlier this is their graduation day
the question that comes in my mind right
now is
nothing sacred any longer
probably the worst thing
that I've seen in my life Keisha Allen
was looking for her goddaughter who had
just graduated when the shooting started
it was just total chaos there were books
for the diplomas all over the ground
there were tapped all over the ground
there were shoes and glasses and
pocketbooks Ellen said she saw students
among the people injured there were two
of them on the ground in their gown
still shot the police chief did not
release a motive but said he believes
the suspect knew at least one of the
victims it's disgusting and cowardly
behavior when you have a crowd like this
innocent people are going to be caught
up in the Mayhem and that's what
happened today
Allen told us that her goddaughter and
her family are okay the five injured
range in age from 14 to 58 a
nine-year-old was also hit by a car amid
the chaos but is okay the police chief
said the suspect had four weapons all of
them handguns Nate
Nicole thank you